puisque nous parlons enfants et il
serait bon que nous nous attardions un
petit peu sur le cas de ceux qui sont
trop petits cheveux dire trop petit
physiquement ce ne sont pas d'ailleurs
forcément des nains au sens médical du
terme
aujourd'hui le mise à la santé avait
choisi de consacrer une journée à ce
problème qui n'est pas que médical mais
aussi psychologiques et sociales
il n'est en effet un enfant sur mille
dans cette situation fait nouveau ces
retards de croissance ne sont plus
aujourd'hui une fatalité on peut y
remédier dans certains cas suivront
martin alain renaut écrit sans rire ou à
l'hôpital saint vincent de paul à paris
christine un maître 04 6 ans et demi
elle aurait dû mesurer à son âge à
mettre case manque 11 cm on cherche à
comprendre pourquoi à vannes à 17 ans 1
m tous
on a du mal à la considérer comme une
adulte
géraldine 13 ans et demi un maître 25 au
lieu d'un mètre 55
elle est plus petit que ses camarades de
4e et elle en souffre
quel âge vous avez 24 ans ils vont
mesurer combien à 25 ans et normalement
vous devriez mesurer combien ça vous
gêne beaucoup
disons qu est ce que vous faites dans la
vie et ça vous gêne pourquoi mais avec
les copains les filles en gros on peut
distinguer deux sortes de retard de
croissance
le retard de croissance constitutionnel
ce sont des enfants qui à un moment
donné se sont arrêté de grandir pendant
un an le retard de croissance est
d'autant plus important que le temps
pendant lequel ils se sont arrêtés deux
grands directs
non puis la croissance repart
normalement sur ce type de retard qu'il
aura tard constitutionnel est
certainement le plus fréquent est très
loin on a aucune possibilité puisque
tout ce qu'on peut constater c'est ce
sont des choses qui se sont passées
plusieurs années auparavant et les
processus de croissance sont devenus
normaux
les petites tailles sur lesquels on peut
quelque chose sont dans le groupe des
petites tailles à vitesse de croissance
réduite à dire que ce sont des enfants
qui ne prennent pas le nombre de
centimètres requis de parents et on est
contemporain du phénomène ces enfants là
ne pourront pas tous être soigné mais
certains d'entre eux peuvent depuis peu
espérer rattraper le retard
ce sont ceux dont l'hypophyse et la
thyroïde fonctionne très mal
c'est le cas de cette jeune femme turque
qui va pouvoir grandir grâce à des
hormones de remplacement l'idéal serait
qu'elle atteigne un mètre cinquante
c'est à dire qu'on parvienne à lui
rajouter la moitié de sa taille actuelle
ce n'est pas certain mais c'est encore
possible malgré ses 17 ans et cela grâce
à une hormone de croissance
extraite l'hypophyse de cadavre et qu'il
faudra lui administré à raison d'une
injection tous les deux jours pendant au
moins cinq ans un traitement long et
très onéreux mais prometteur que l'on
appliquera aussi à sa soeur 13 ans 91 cm